Trascrizione: Paola B
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
(Musica)
Grazie mille.
Buona sera a tutti.
Mi presento. Sono Astrid Morganne.
Sono una life coach.
Mi occupo di formazione professionale e di sviluppo personale.
Negli ultimi anni
mi sono dedicata allo studio
di una cosa un po' particolare:
la funzione cerebrale, come la mente
organizza l'informazione e le idee.
Ora mi aggancerò al discorso di Andrea
che ha parlato prima dell'organizzazione del tempo.
Siamo in un momento storico
in cui il tempo ci sfugge in continuazione.
E la prima domanda che vorrei farvi è:
Chi di voi ha una agenda?
O utilizza una agenda?
OK. Alzate le mani.
Chi di voi utilizza una agenda? OK. Quasi tutti.
Potrei anche chiedervi:
Chi di voi usa due agende? Tre agende?
Generalmente una sul cellulare,
una è cartacea,
perché a volte ci piace prendere appunti,
una è informatica, il computer,
un'altra potrebbe essere umana, un partner.
"Ti ricordi stasera che andiamo a cena?"
O un figlio magari: "Domani facciamo questa cosa".
Quindi noi organizziamo il tempo in continuazione.
Poi la seconda cosa, organizziamo le cose
perché abbiamo bisogno di chiarezza.
Quindi, la mattina - classico esempio -
apriamo il nostro armadio --
e troviamo - speriamo non a casa nostra -
una cosa di questo genere.
Amiamo l'organizzazione anche nelle piccole cose,
perché trovare un armadio di questo genere
quando vogliamo vestirci la mattina in fretta
sarebbe un caos, e ci fa perdere tempo.
Quindi tendiamo ad avere una superorganizzazione delle cose,
soprattutto l'armadio: vogliamo sapere dove abbiamo messo la camicia,
dove abbiamo messo un pantalone e così via.
E questa è l'organizzazione delle cose.
Poi arriviamo anche all'organizzazione dell'ambiente in cui viviamo.
Le nostre case, i nostri appartamenti sono divisi in varie aree:
il bagno, la camera piuttosto che la cucina.
Magari ottimizziamo i tempi e mettiamo la cucina vicino al soggiorno.
Così perdiamo pochissimo tempo per farci da mangiare --
-- facciamo pochi passi, troviamo un divano, mangiamo e dormiamo sul divano.
Quindi ottimizziamo anche tantissimo i tempi.
Organizziamo i tempi, organizziamo le cose,
organizziamo gli ambienti.
E poi arriviamo al lavoro:
come facciamo per organizzare appunti e informazioni?
Questo a qualcuno richiama qualcosa in mente, no?
Pensate al computer pieno di post-it --
o la parete dove lavoriamo --
Al giorno d'oggi riceviamo tantissime informazioni.
In questo momento storico,
in una giornata viene creata così tanta informazione
più di quanta ci è umanamente possibile assorbire in tutta una vita.
E cosa facciamo per organizzare questa informazione?
Continuiamo con i post-it? o i fogli volanti?
Ne troviamo dappertutto, anche in macchina
e perdiamo queste preziose informazioni.
Io organizzo le informazioni
attraverso le mappe mentali.
Questo è un esempio simile a quello che trovate nella vostra brochure.
Organizziamo i pensieri, le informazioni in modo utile.
E cosa si fa con le mappe mentali?
Non solo si organizzano i pensieri,
ma si guadagna tempo -- come?
Con la stessa formazione presente nel cervello.
Questa è la rappresentazione di un neurone.
Nel neurone, c'è un nucleo, il soma,
poi una diramazione, l'assone e infine i dendriti.
Questa è una formazione di come funziona il nostro cervello.
Io utilizzo la stessa cosa.
Quando si fa una mappa mentale
si mette al centro della mappa, quindi nel nucleo, nel soma
il progetto o l'informazione che sto ricevendo
e poi lo si sviluppa attraverso le diramazioni.
Questo perché? Perché la mappa è mentale
-- il primo fattore è l'organizzazione dei pensieri,
il secondo fattore è pianificare le cose con chiarezza,
non avere 43mila appunti, dei libri,
le riviste, il computer, le cartelle --
su un foglio trovate tutta la pianificazione:
un foglio solo!
E la terza cosa, è la memorizzazione.
È molto importante, a lungo termine però,
perché ora non serve a niente memorizzare informazioni
che durano un giorno o una settimana.
Non siamo più a scuola.
A scuola ci poteva andare bene per fare gli esami.
Però adesso ci interessa che il tempo
che usiamo per studiare una cosa o per sviluppare una cosa
rimanga nel nostro cervello a lungo termine.
Quindi vediamo la memorizzazione come funziona.
La memorizzazione funziona attraverso immagini.
L'immagine è cruciale per l'essere umano.
Noi pensiamo attraverso le immagini, non tanto attraverso le parole.
Quello che rimane nella nostra mente sono immagini.
La specie umana ha iniziato a fare disegni sulle caverne
ben prima di poter parlare.
Un'immagine è un raggruppato di tantissime parole.
Quindi utilizziamo un'immagine per memorizzare.
Poi utilizziamo i colori.
I colori sono importantissimi per la memoria.
Qui al TED, il colore principale è il rosso.
Lo vediamo dappertutto.
Il rosso è molto importante per noi.
Durante la nostra evoluzione il rosso è stato un archetipo del sangue.
Quindi era molto importante per noi ricordarci che
questo colore ci richiama una pericolosità.
O è il mio proprio sangue che sto perdendo e quindi devo fare attenzione
o magari ho ferito un animale o qualcuno per poter sopravvivere --
quindi il rosso -- perché la donna vestita di rosso attrae l'attenzione
o una bella Ferrari rossa?
Perché richiama l'archetipo della sopravvivenza della specie.
Quindi più utilizziamo appunti colorati,
più ce ne ricordiamo a lungo termine.
E la terza cosa, sono le emozioni.
Le emozioni sono il chelante di tutto ciò che c'è nella nostra memorizzazione.
È quasi impossibile ricordarsi di una cosa
senza che sia legata o chelata a un'emozione.
Quindi, tre cose:
le immagini, i colori e le emozioni.
Cosa facciamo a scuola? Prendiamo appunti, come?
In modo lineare, generalmente in nero o in blu scuro
e ovviamente l'emozione che ci leghiamo non è molto piacevole.
Ed è per quello che perdiamo tantissimo di quello che abbiamo studiato a scuola.
Ora vediamo che queste mappe mentali,
queste strutture possiamo utilizzarle benissimo nelle aziende
per creare un organigramma, una pianificazione,
un progetto, un obiettivo comune o una visione comune.
In un team è molto importante che tutte le persone che lavorano in azienda
o su un progetto
abbiano la stessa visione.
Altrimenti c'è un dispendio molto grande a livello energetico
e l'obiettivo potrebbe non essere portato a termine proprio per questo.
Quindi si fanno dei gruppi di lavoro a livello di mappe mentali.
E poi per me è molto importante, e mi piace moltissimo,
il lavoro con i ragazzi e a livello di privati.
I ragazzi oggi devono imparare tantissime cose a scuola
e hanno difficoltà a ricordare tutto.
Quindi si fanno le mappe mentali.
Veramente ho dei grandissimi risultati
primo perché piace
e piace perché è colorato.
È la prima cosa che fanno i bambini:
prendono i colori e disegnano dappertutto,
anche sulle pareti.
Poi arriviamo noi, che a 30-40 anni
la matita colorata non la vediamo più
ed è un peccato perché qualsiasi persona che usa i colori, si diverte.
E aiuta la memorizzazione, il divertimento.
Qui vediamo questo ragazzo che si diverte tantissimo.
In realtà sta studiando.
È tutto quello che ha fatto.
Si è ricordato tutto quando ha fatto gli esami
Adesso per chiudere il mio intervento, vorrei chiedervi:
Cosa potrebbe cambiare nella vostra vita
se da domani imparate ad organizzare anche le vostre idee
e l'informazione che ricevete durante tutto il giorno?
Perché abbiamo tanto da organizzare nella nostra vita.
Quindi le cose, il tempo però anche le informazioni
ora come ora
sono molto importanti
da prendere dentro di noi,
all'infinito,
per il tempo che ci rimane da vivere.
Vi ringrazio.
(Applauso)